hello reject nation rageh alba in the
hizzy and I'm John JM Valente is one of
our top pledge patrons on our patreon
page one of our reward tiers whatever
video patron requests Greg and John must
do whether it be a discussion or a
reaction 98% of the time is a reaction
and then when it's a discussion it's a
long-ass discussion we've noticed
something
reaction for Dali socha Panda brings the
lol's for your vote semi final five
Britain's Got Talent
okay Brett and Scott Thailand's Got
Talent
yeah I did what you would do and you do
[Music]
just like that please copy icon
somebody wrote that you got Simon Cowell
de yeah
[Music]
it's misleading cuz amazing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to be part of the transaction so I just
took the change
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow Wow I hope this dude gets huge man
that was some funny funny ass [ __ ] right
there I've seen a lot of like I've been
to flappers comedy store a lot and I've
been to like a lot of stand-up venues in
the LA area it's often times that I'll
see an African comedian like a comedian
from Africa do stand-up some of these
bits are like are similar types of bits
they don't quite Orton likes ya but they
don't quite land he nailed it here
because that was that was some hilarious
stuff and I love any stand-up bit that
reminds you that while there's harsh
times is always gonna be tough times
always gonna be a harsh times in the
world there's still a lot of great
things that joke about like two years
ago Soviet option was a great joke a
great punch line to that landing that
punch line on a great point is my
favorite kind of comedy yeah yes solid
message and a funny ass line to follow
yeah you walk the tightrope really well
a lot of the time because there were so
there were certain moments where he
would come in both with something clever
but also like you said something pointed
you know I thought it broke a lot of the
tension hot people it's like you saw the
kind of laughter that caught people off
guard
yeah off guards because some of the
punchlines were like mean humor but they
don't feel nasty they don't feel mean
you know yeah like the joke about I was
I'm not ambitious and I you're the one
homer in the bar I approached or the
joke about the fat mirror and his eyes
are the same those are mean jokes
technically but his energy and his
delivery in the ways talking feels good
spirited about it yeah it kind of has
that that been their quality yes like
it's not like he's just [ __ ] on it
it's sort of like but but
I've probably seen myself that way too
like the the my eyes are that way yeah I
also I kind of thought like oh I've seen
myself that way see it's nice to see
Simon Cowell crack up that much he's got
a soul and some somewhere inside that
sweater
well thanks Jan for introducing this
comedian to us I love stand-up comedy I
mean I don't know anyway I usually watch
a stand-up at least once a week or
listen to at least once a week being
introduced to a new comic always gets
because I usually go through everyone's
special seeing all Dave Chappelle's not
just the Netflix when they listen to all
the old ones and he'll like and you find
someone you the fun I guess is when you
can just start jumping into different
routines yeah when you find that person
it's like when you find that next band
he's that kind of person I feel like I
could listen to a lot yeah I mean every
every one of his bits you know got me
laughing at some point like even the
ones that weren't as strong as some of
the others I still like I have the
rhythm going and I was enjoying it the
whole time yeah the the weakest
punchline I thought cuz I thought it was
a great topic to touch on but it didn't
quite hit a woman paying for the bill
because that is a very it's something I
can relate to when I'm like I don't have
money right now yeah and then the woman
has to pay that's a very embarrassing
moment for me there's a funny punchline
about getting the change yeah that's the
only one every all the other ones hit
really strong yeah yeah well it seemed
to work most when he was getting on a
more pointed topic than like yeah you
know who pays on a date it's kind of
tried-and-true so it's yeah a little
less specific I felt like then some of
the other you know topics just get so
fed up you like come on tongue get it
together
Jan Valente thank you once again and oh
you guys shirt your letter later now we
just need to do a Google hangout thing
we will have honored all your awards yet
when you're a high pledge subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell and make sure to check out our
patreon it's like a second youtube
channel full length means ik v do
reactions and TV show reactions
throughout the week Q&A a lot of other
stuff a lot and understand a lot